SPEAKER: When I was a sysadmin
back in pre-cloud days,
I had lots of little
scheduled shell scripts
on my workstation for admin
tasks like taking backups.
But now that many
systems are in the cloud,
it makes sense to run our
admin scripts there too.
Let's say we want to run this
Firestore database backup
every night in the cloud.
First, we copy this simple Go
program that listens for HTTP
and invokes our shell script.
Finally, we deploy the
container to Cloud Run.
If we hit the URL of our
new Cloud Run service,
our shell script
will run at once.
If we set up Cloud
Scheduler to hit that URL,
the script can run unattended
in the middle of the night.
It can report status
with the echo command.
The output will go to
Cloud Logging, where we
can look at it in the morning.
We should also restrict access
to our Cloud Run service.
See the link in the description.
Now we have a script
that runs nightly
without having to maintain
a server or virtual machine
for it.